welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact on November 30 1954
Ann Hodges was taking a nap on her couch
in the little town of Oak Grove Alabama
suddenly without warning a
grapefruit-sized rock crashed through
her ceiling bounced off a large wooden
radio and struck her on the hip
remarkably the only injury she sustained
was a nasty-looking bruise and said it
was a meteorite
when experts examine the stone they
agreed her report also matched with
local sightings that same day of a
bright red light trailing through the
sky this experience made an the only
verified person in history who ever had
been struck by a meteorite in 1956 the
meteorite was donated to the Alabama
Museum of Natural History where it's
still on display today in 2013 a Florida
State College astronomer told National
Geographic that a person has a better
chance of getting hit by a tornado a
bolt of lightning and a hurricane all at
the same time than being hit by a
meteorite and surviving no doubt it must
be a little disconcerting to be hit by a
space rock you know the Bible says that
in the last days there'll be a rock that
will fall from the heavens and bring an
end to all earthly kingdoms stay with
his friends we're going to learn more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at
1-800-805-3030
and our co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome listening France to Bible
answers live and if you have a Bible
question some question about living the
Christian life we will do our best to
search the word together and find the
answers lines are open right now if you
want to call in a chance your program
your question will be on tonight's
program just go to 800 god says at eight
it's eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven one more time 804 63 72
97 we'll bring your question into the
program and again there's plenty of
phone lines open my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross and good
evening friends pastor Doug let's stop
the program with prayer dear Father in
Heaven what a privilege once again to be
able to open up your word and study
together me ask the Holy Spirit to come
and God our hearts Lord lead us into a
clearer understanding of the Bible for
the truth will set us free bless our
time together in Jesus name Amen
amen pastor day you opened the program
by talking about a meteor that I mean
these from time to time hear about
meteors that hit the earth but this one
went through the roof and actually hit a
person and the person survived the
chance of that happening I think he's
rather remarkable but quite a story
to be hit of course it wasn't a direct
hit but it bounced off something and
then hit the person and they seemed fine
yeah Wow that doesn't happen every day I
guess then there was a legal battle what
happened just a little subtitle to this
story or a little additional trivia is
that then there was a fight over who got
to keep the rock she was in a rented
house and so the landlord said that's my
rock cuz it hit my house and she said no
but we were renting the house and so
they were they were in court actually
fighting over the meteorite but they
ended up donating it to
the museum but yeah that would that make
you wonder if he'd done something wrong
if you get struck from by a stone from
the heavens but if you know where I'm
going with this there's a story in the
Bible it's actually a dream that King
Nebuchadnezzar the king of Babylon had
while the children of Israel were
captive in his empire and it was a dream
about this large image a large Idol made
out of different materials the head was
gold and the arms were silver and the
belly was brass and the legs were iron
and the feet were iron and clay and it
represented all the different kingdoms
and if you study this vision it's an
amazing outline of the major world
empires that would control or influence
God's people through time and so far all
of that dream has come true
just proving the prophecies of the Bible
except the very last part it's as a
stone that was cut without hands now let
me read it to you a matter of fact it's
the annual to verse 34 and I'll read
verse 35 as well thou saw'st till a
stone was cut out without hands which
smote the image on the feet that were
iron and clay and broke them in pieces
then was the iron and the clay the brass
the silver and the gold broken in pieces
together and became like the chaff of
the summer threshing floor and the wind
carried them away so though no place was
found for them and the stone that smote
the image became a great mountain and
filled the whole earth and so that stone
is of course Christ the Rock of Ages is
talking about the coming of Christ god's
kingdom jesus said do you hear these
words of mine and doom you're like a
wise man building on the rock and the
kingdom of Christ is going to come and
pulverize all these other world empires
sometimes when we've taught and preached
on that lesson it almost looks like a
meteorite coming out of the sky and
striking that giant image you know we
have a lesson that talks about this is
probably one of the most amazing
prophecies in the Bible that you find in
Daniel chapter 2 the prophecy of the
image in the stone and we have a lesson
we'll send you a free copy of that in
order to get it just give us a call on
our resource phone number that number is
six seven four seven and you can ask for
the store achill lesson called the
Millennial man
again that number is 885 six seven four
seven and asked for the study guide or
actually it's a historical lesson called
the Millennial man we'll be happy to
send that to anybody who calls and asks
great information in that study yep
all right we already see who is on the
hill telephones and we have by the way a
few lines that are still open 800 if you
want to call in with your question we
know we've got a lot of folks listening
on satellite as they're driving across
the country some people are stranded in
weather may as well call on a Bible
question 800 God says 800 for six three
seven two nine seven alright the first
caller that we have is Brian listening
from Idaho Brian welcome to the program
hello hi thanks for calling hey my wife
and I we were having our Bible study and
we're reading about several of God's
promises and we came across you know
most of them have to do with faith and
we were looking up faith what is faith
and we came across Hebrews 11:1 and we
we just we just can't figure it out well
let me read that to everybody listening
Hebrews 11:1 says now faith is the
substance of things hoped for and the
evidence of things not seen and
basically what he's saying there is you
know our faith is usually based on some
past evidence but it's the substance of
what you're hoping for that you haven't
received yet you know I have faith that
they'll be breakfast in the morning I
haven't seen it yet but based on past
evidence I believe it's going to be
there and so all through life everyday
we live by faith in different areas an
example would be a matter of fact this
next week I'm going to be teaching on
David and Goliath and part of the reason
David had faith
that he could kill Goliath it hadn't
been experienced yet it wasn't seen yet
is based on the evidence that he had
seen god help him kill a bear and kill a
lion and so this is I think what Paul
the writer of Hebrews is saying here in
this chapter and he goes through the
chapter and he talks about the faith of
many of the great Bible heroes here and
they stepped out in faith trusting God
based on past promises that were
fulfilled that makes me see that's why
the Lord said the children of Israel
should have had faith because he gave
them so much evidence that he would take
care of him when he fed them with manna
from heaven and water from the rock and
a pillar of fire and all the miracles he
says I've given you evidence so that you
should have faith in things that aren't
seen that because I took care of you in
the past I've given you evidence trust
me in the future okay that makes lots of
sense well thank you very much and I'm
glad you called you know um we don't
really have a book I was thinking about
something on faith but I have something
on faith it's a pretty basic Christian
teaching we could offer but you might
really enjoy our amazing fact study
guide that we offer tonight on the
prophecy of Daniel 2 and we'll send you
a free copy Brian a number to call is
883 five six seven four seven you can
ask for this study guide or historical
lesson called millennial man will be
able to send that to you again that
number is 885 six seven four seven that
is our resource phone line if you have a
Bible question that line to call here to
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven and let's
see we've got Lord iya listening in
Michigan low dear welcome wait I don't
think that fault line I think we had an
end
let's try Peter see if Peter is ready
Peter welcome to the program get real
close to your phone okay I
have a very good phone so it's I got to
kind of yell into it we can you though
okay and you know Bible question yes
five four proverbs seven bowls are kind
of similar talking about an adulterous
woman I'm looking it up right now let me
see in Proverbs yeah he's got a whole
section there where Solomon is talking
about the adulterous woman and man a
figure that's I typed in the wrong thing
say something s Roz why I type well I
think you know the Bible that speak
about all warnings it does warn against
those that would lead others into sin
and one of the points that was mentioned
is adulterous woman and it says her feet
are close to hell or lead to hell that's
the ultimate destiny of those who follow
that line them and that way of living
and thinking yeah yeah well it's kind of
like this this is telling us something
about like Potiphar's wife you know
Potiphar was alway on business and she
was trying to seduce Joseph and so it's
the same same thing I'm still looking
this up I know I know I know it's there
and sometimes when you go from one
translation to another
it says proverbs 22 the mouth of an
immoral woman is a deep pit proverbs 23
27 for our harlot is a deep hit and let
me see here there's proverbs 5 3 it may
be the one you're looking for
for the lips of a forbidden woman drip
honey and her speech is smoother than
oil but the end she's bitter as wormwood
and sharp as a two-edged sword her feet
go down to death is that the one you're
thinking about yeah the feet go down
death her steps lay hold of hell I think
that's the one that's proverbs five five
well it's not the Spirit of God you know
here's the here it's proverbs seven as
when you're looking for in proverbs 7 it
talks about oh let me see I just want to
make sure I get this oh hey that's quite
a it's proverbs 7 behold a woman meets
him she's dressed as a prostitute she
has a wily heart she's loud and wayward
her feet do stray from home goes on did
says she seizes him and kisses him she
says my husband is away that's probably
the one you're talking about my husband
is not at home he's gone on a long
journey with much seductive speech he
persuades him and her her a smooth talk
she compels him at once he follows her
so I'm pretty sure that's the passage
you're talking about and that's proverbs
7 shoes it goes from lights verse 10 on
so what's the question though connected
with that yeah whenever a person is
trapped in some kind of immoral behavior
you could ask the Lord to do for her
what he did for Mary Magdalene Bible
says that Jesus cast Seven Devils out of
Mary and it seems to imply Mary was a
great sinner you can read in John
chapter 12 and I think it's a Luke
chapter
I'll 11 and 8 talks about the dinner so
you know if God kiddin all of us yeah
you know David made the same mistake he
was unfaithful in that area and just say
Lord you know work in their hearts and
help them long for salvation and purity
and God the Lord can do that well God
will have to be the judge of that but
obviously when this happens there is a
battle between good and evil going on
and so you know you just want to pray
that the Holy Spirit will bring
conviction and comfort in their life and
he can do that so hope that helps a
little bit we appreciate your question
Peter all right next caller is Lord iya
listening in Michigan
Odia welcome to the program Lorelai okay
I see we got an i instead of an L in our
computer system here and your question
tonight different language because I was
at my young adults group tonight was
really into it and was starting to speak
into the microphone which kind of like
distracted me from focusing on talking
to God because I felt like if you're
going to you should be doing a
microphone in front of the church unless
you have someone that could interpret it
especially if you're trying to make it a
Dodd moment between an individual and
God well like your own you're on the
right track Lorelai first of all there's
a book we'll send you I just want to
tell you that right away it's called
understanding tongues it goes through
what the Bible says and doesn't say
about tongues because there's a lot of
good
fusion you know we believe in all the
gifts of the Spirit that are mentioned
but the gift of tongues when you see it
in the Bible is not a person babbling
incoherently where no one around
understands or they don't even
understand you don't see any example of
that in the Bible when they spoke in
tongues in the Bible God gave the
Apostles the ability to speak in other
languages that they did not formally
know or study for the purpose of
preaching the gospel in those languages
that's what happened in Acts chapter two
in acts 19 in acts 10 Jesus said in mark
16 you will speak with other tongues he
gave them the ability to speak other
languages it would be like you going to
visit people in Japan assuming you don't
speak Japanese and all of a sudden the
Lord miraculously gives you the ability
to speak a new tongue
meaning a new language and you can speak
Japanese and you share the gospel with
people there this is what the gift of
tongues was it had nothing to do with
just becoming overwhelmed with some
static feeling and then babbling as you
say that's gibberish Paul and first
Corinthians 14 said I'd rather speak
five words with my understanding that I
might instruct others than 10,000 in an
unknown tongue and then I think he says
in verse 9 first Corinthians 14 he said
if the trumpet gives an uncertain sound
who will know how to prepare for the
battle if people just make incoherent no
he's on the trumpet then the military
can't order their troops around it it
just didn't work so God wants our speech
to communicate thought the idea that our
speech is just babbling well that's what
happened at the Tower of Babel that's
not God's plan so what do you think it
is then like I'm wondering like what
would it do you think well if you trace
the history of it some of the popular -
speaking in tongues that you see on TV
or pastors are praying and they spray
COFF into these languages that did not
happen a hundred and fifty years ago for
the first 1,900 years of the church you
didn't see that that's something that is
a fairly comparatively new phenomenon
and you know it largely came out of the
self what happened in many cultures in
many religions when people would they'd
pray that they could go into this trance
and speak the language of the gods and
it found its way into some of the
churches in the south and then it went
to LA the Azusa Street Church and it
started going mainline but and they said
this is what happened with the Holy
Spirit and I don't want to judge what's
going on and what the Spirit is I've got
a friend who's a pastor he happens to be
a pastor of my denomination and when I
studied this with him he said you know
when I first started speaking in tongues
he used to be a charismatic pastor where
he spoke in tongues or at least a member
and he said it was wonderful feeling
it's a prayer language and and I studied
with him he said well if this isn't from
God then I want him to take it away he
said it never happened again so you just
you you don't see Jesus ever doing that
do you no you don't ever see Jesus just
break off and start babbling and saying
this is the filling of the Holy Spirit
Jesus said I'll give you the Holy Spirit
that you can be my witnesses he gives
the spirit so we can teach and preach
and witness in other languages
it's one of the gifts of the Spirit
please send for the book you or anyone
listening please send for the book
called understanding tongues and it's a
lot of confusion on this we believe in
the gifts of the Spirit but this is one
that's being distorted a little by some
dear people again the number to call is
883 five six seven four seven you can
answer the book called understanding
tongues however to send it to anybody
who calls and asks or you can go to the
amazing facts website you can do both if
you wish and you can read a PDF version
of the book at amazing facts dot o-r-g
just type in the search bar
understanding tongues and it'll be
directing you to that book all right
next caller is Lance and he's listening
in Colorado Lance welcome to the program
hi thanks for taking my call yeah thank
you for calling yes so my question is um
I'm familiar with clean and unclean
meats and Leviticus but it also talks
about not having any blood so I guess my
question is if you even within
the Queen needs to do those need to be
kosher if you're following that well
yeah you know I'm I'm glad you
understand this a lot of Christians
don't realize that both new and old
testament still reinforces the the
health laws and you can you can look in
oh you can look in Acts for instance a
very very New Testament book Acts of the
Apostles chapter 15 and they said to
write to all the Gentile believers that
they should abstain from things polluted
by idols from sexual immorality from
things strangled now the reason they
said you're to abstain from things
strangled is there's a couple ways to
kill an animal before you butcher it and
one was to strangle it and that way it
dies with the blood still in it
what they were supposed to do is cut the
throat and train the blood whether there
was a bird or beast and then they could
prepare the meat but it says here to
abstain from things strangled in from
blood and so that goes all the way back
to Noah it says you should abstain from
blood and you know the life is in the
blood disease can be transferred from
animal to animal through the blood and
so God never intended people to eat
blood clean or unclean animal and that's
in the new in the Old Testament and so
if a person is going to eat meat the
clean meats then they should you know
make sure that it's got the blood
drained out of it I'm a vegetarian so I
don't have a think about it and I've
been a vegetarian for 38 years now I
think except I think I could think
people slipped it to me once or twice
you could say I'm about 98% vegetarian
oh I feel so much better yeah yeah this
is making me go more close to 100
percent because that's you can't really
verify you don't always know exactly
what happened to it before you it's on
your plate yeah well you know it's
interesting that a lot of food that you
buy has been at some point boiled or
sterilized in some way before you get it
to your table
but when you buy meat they don't do
anything to clean it
it it goes from the time it's cut with a
knife they wrap it up and they send it
off and it is not you always hear about
people you know having to they get a
coli or Salmonella or different things
like that and it's often connected with
me mad cow and you don't ever have mad
cucumber so you don't have to worry
about that no I agree anyway but yeah so
if the person's gonna eat meat you know
you buy it sometimes you at the Marquee
see it's just swimming and blood cells
so they haven't really drained all the
blood out necessarily have to be stamped
I mean it doesn't have to be senator ya
need to make sure it's you know not
bathed in blood for the right part you
just need to do make sure it is dry of
that as possible I have a better way of
saying it you know we have a study guide
dealing with the subject of health and
food and council that the Bible gives on
that it's called God's free health plan
won't be happy to send us to your land
so anybody who calls and asks the number
is 883 five six seven four seven and you
can ask to the study guide called God's
free health plan if you have a Bible
question a phone line here studio is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven we have a few lines open good
time to give us a call eight hundred
four sixty three seventy to ninety seven
next call II sandy listening from
Illinois sandy welcome to the program I
have a question how do you deepen your
trust in God he's done amazing things in
my life to the low points and the high
points but there's a sticking point from
my childhood and I often I'm sort of at
an impasse and you want a deeper
relationship yeah well I wish more
people would call an asset question
because that that's something I wish
that we would all hunger after the Bible
tells us in Jeremiah chapter 29 thirteen
you'll search for me and you'll find me
when you search for me
with all of your heart and if you want
more faith you can read in Romans
chapter 10 I think it's verse 17 faith
comes by hearing and hearing by the Word
of God spending time in the word
doing it religiously even if we don't
feel like it sometimes but reading the
word and it will bless us and more time
in prayer and sometimes prayer is not
just talking prayers listening it's been
time on your knees and make it the first
part of your day and then ask the Lord
part of the Christian faith is not only
praying reading your Bible it's letting
your light shine ask the Lord when you
pray every day say Lord give me an
opportunity to share my faith with
someone else during this day and you'd
be surprised how many times he'll do
that you just ask him and say help me to
recognize those opportunities to tell
someone else about my faith as you share
your faith as you pray as you study his
word that's where the real the strength
comes from you know you in the sanctuary
there is a holy place and in the holy
place there were three articles of
furniture the candlestick the altar of
incense and the table of bread the bread
is your bread of life the altar is
prayer the candlestick is witnessing let
your light shine do those things and
you'll be blessed sandy hey friends
we're gonna take a brief break
and by the way sandy we do have a book
you can get online called the ultimate
resource on the Bible I'll send you a
free copy when you call a resource
number don't go away we're coming back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture the Egyptians built pyramids to
help guide the spirits of their leaders
Rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead even
the Bible tells of a king that used a
witch to contact the spirit of a
deceased prophet today ancient folklore
of spirits and apparitions have gone
from mere superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true why do
these stories persist does it even
matter we invite you to look inside and
find out for yourself visit death truth
com every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live we still have a few
phone lines open if you have a Bible
related question call us at
1-800-805-3030
and Jean Ross
for more Bible answers live welcome
listening friends if you joined along
the way this is Bible answers live and
you can call in with your Bible
questions we have some lines open here's
the number again 800 God says 800 for 63
72 97 and my name is Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross and if you have a
Bible question as mentioned earlier the
number is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven eight hundred four
sixty three seventy to ninety seven and
we'll be able to get your Bible question
on the air today
my next holy is a Harry listening in
Queens New York
Harry welcome to the program how you
doing Jesus likewise I started job and I
had a question why Joe was considered to
be why job is considered like a
christ-like person yeah I was yet
there's so there's several reasons that
many Bible scholars believe that job is
a type of Christ
for one thing the sufferings that Joe
went through no one suffered like Jobe
except Jesus of course suffered more
that the devil specifically focused on
job that God focused on on a job and
said have you considered my servant
Jesus is called the servant in the
prophecies in the Old Testament you can
look at you know job talks about his
thirst Jesus said I thirst from the
cross it talks about casting Lots in the
book of Job it talked about that with
Jesus it says they spit on him
they spit on Christ there's just several
similarities in fact if you go to our
website you'll see that I've got a
lesson that I did where I talk about job
and I talk about the types of Christ in
the story of Job and I think you'll find
that a real blessing hearing the there's
a number of characters in the Bible that
are like types of Christ I've got a book
called shadows of light that goes
through all the not all but many of the
Bible types the characters like David
and Joseph and Moses Moses how they are
like Jesus and Jobe was one of them so I
hope that helps a little bit and we
appreciate your call Harry I mixed cold
a is you know what I just think you've
mastered a we have a book called the
sign now that's dealing with Jonah and
not job would be a great book but no we
don't have one on a sermon series as
well let's you online well they can look
in there's a sermon series online called
Jesus in the Bible and one whole section
is just on Jobe so they'll enjoy that I
think all right I next Kohli's marla
listening in Arbonne california marlin
welcome to the program yes thank you so
much such a privilege yes my question
for you
pastor Doug and pastor Oz is
I'm glad you brought up Daniel - it's
one of my favorite topics and I had the
privilege of being in Israel for a while
and studying the language I looked up in
the Bible what mountain what the word
for mountain is when
the stone comes out of this mountain
Daniel - I think it's verse 35 and 45 it
mentions mountain right and so my
question is when I looked it up its
Strong's numbering oh five and two 906
and it says tour now tour is the word
for rose like the rose of stone in
Exodus 20:8 verse 17 is talking about
the Rose of stone that the breastplate
you know on the breastplate of the
priests they have the twelve tribes and
the twelve stones and and here it is in
rows and so I'm just so fascinated by
this I know that every word must mean
something and we're talking about the
end times and it's so important so my
question is why would the word mountain
which actually means the word rose have
a stone coming out and joining you know
the feet of Evelyn alright just go ahead
I'm sorry yeah I was just fascinated by
that you know what's been I think what's
being communicated here in Daniel
chapter two and one of those is verse 35
the stone that struck the image became a
great mountain and filled the whole
earth and it talks about a stone that
was cut without hands oh the real
message are one of the real messages I
should say in Daniel - it's contrasting
the worship of God with the worship of
the heathen the God of gods against the
gods of the world the world kingdoms
worshipped idols that's why this whole
image is an idol of all the different
metals and stones and silver and gold
and so forth but then it says that when
the Hebrews made their altar they were
to make it with stone that was not cut
by a man's hands they knew as soon as
they started chiseling on the stone
they'd be tempted to make an idol God
said here to get rough stone regular
stone don't Hewitt don't cut it and so
it's basically saying that the stone
that strikes the image is a stone that
is set aside for worshipping God and it
grows to a great mountain and of course
the ten commandments that Moses
recieves were on Mount Sinai and those
were two tables of stone the Word of God
those two tables soared two edges along
the profits the two witnesses it's all
talking about the Word of God which is
Christ bringing down that giant image
the kingdoms of the world and the false
teachings so yeah that's very
interesting what you said I'd have to
delve into the the Hebrew of that more
I've never looked at that carefully and
what that word Mountain the root of that
is there and appreciate your sharing
that with us
Marta and tower Marlon thank you very
much for your call I mixed call a is
let's see we've got Nita who is
listening from Kettle Falls Washington
meet and welcome to the program I know
faith and trust I believe
we're very well interconnected and I
know that it's impossible to please God
without faith but piggybacking on what
sandy was asking when you've been hurt
very very very badly I'm a small child
on up and you know you can't trust
humans because they just hurt how do you
trust God
how can one because I know it affects my
relationship with Christ I'm sure it
does Sandy's and a lot of us out here
how do we learn to trust God that's a
great question
you know and I I meet people they say
you know I grew up with a father that
was difficult or cruel and now the Bible
says I should love my Heavenly Father
and how do I do that when I had such
problems with my earthly father and you
in your mind you need to divorce any bad
memories that you've had with an earthly
parent or father people from God don't
don't hang that on him and don't connect
it with him and just realize that people
may let you down God will never let you
down people are sinful God is holy
people are sometimes selfish and wicked
God is good and just and it's just
realizing there is a being that isn't
not like people that he is you know pure
and holy and good matter of fact the
plan of salvation
designed to restore the image of God
back in people because folks through sin
we've had become very selfish and and
that's really the key because you know a
lot of people in hurt you know you read
in the Bible of folks that were very
apprehensive Mary Magdalene I mentioned
earlier seemed like she had been taken
advantage of and had some bad
experiences but she she learned to love
Jesus and we need to just realize that
He loves us with the pure love and that
he will never let us down he'll never
let us go and I hope that helps a little
think you need appreciate your call my
next call is Teresa listening from New
York Teresa welcome to the program I
have a question in Romans 8:26 you said
likewise this year also help with the
infirmities for what we know know what
we should pray for as we would and the
Spirit Himself making intercession for
us we're groanings which cannot be
uttered mm-hmm and he did searches the
hutt know what what is the mind of the
Spirit because he make it intercession
for the Saints according to the will of
God and we know that more things he
works for the good my praying to God
because I'm praying and there are other
things you know help me so what how can
I help you with a question
here is my print when I ask for prayer
to the Holy Spirit for these things am i
praying to God well typically in the
Bible when we pray the Bible says we
pray to the Father through the spirit in
the name of Jesus there's really no
example of people praying to the spirit
in the Bible God God the spirit is one
of the members of the Trinity you've got
God the Father Son and spirit but we're
always told to pray to the Father and it
doesn't mean God has not or will not
hear your prayers if you had said I'm
gonna pray to Jesus or I'm going to pray
to the spirit that's typically not how
it's done in the Bible but you know
praying to God is the main thing and
just laying your your cares out before
him now trust the Lord yeah you know
because sometimes when when we struggle
and we have those stresses we forget
that God is somehow taking care of us
over the course of our life and he's
gonna take care of you and so you don't
be losing sleep just say Lauren I've got
these issues I'm gonna do my best to
solve the problems but I need your help
and he will a matter of fact oh why
don't we have a quick prayer for you
right now Teresa father in heaven I just
pray that you'll be with Teresa and some
of her struggles she's having it seems
like the pressure bills and debts and
and some of the trials of life are
weighing her down I helped her to know
that you love her you're gonna watch
over her and if you take care of the
birds and the flowers you're gonna take
care of her and so just bless and give
her comfort now we pray in Jesus name
Amen
appreciate your call Teresa and you know
we do have a free book we'll send you on
prayer because you're asking a question
about that and it's gonna it's called
teach us to pray number to call is 883
five six seven four seven that as a
resource phone line and you can ask for
the book called teach us to pray we'll
be happy to send that to you to resaw
calls and asks our next caller is
Rebecca listening from Oregon Rebecca
welcome to the program hi hi I know
where Brooke exists yes we are the
banana Belt of the coast and it's been
so beautiful
three days has just been amazing you
mean you've had three days without rain
that's all in the church but I fell away
and all the way for like I don't know 20
30 years and I recently reaffirmed my
faith I can't remember cause a water
baptism or not probably not but I think
I should get a water one but my question
is is if you're a baptized once before
it does that make even though you fell
away when you come back are you
automatically reaccept it why Jesus or
do you need to get rebaptised well
you're accepted when you return to
Christ but the it might be appropriate
to be rebaptised let's talk about the
firm for just a moment baptism for the
Christian is something like a wedding
ceremony for a marriage now if a couple
gets married and then they have an
argument they need don't need to have
another ceremony but if a couple gets
married and they divorce if they want to
be married again they have to have
another ceremony now if you've totally
walked away from the Lord and you've
kind of dishonored your first commitment
and you say twenty years went by and now
you're returning to the Lord you know
there are examples in the Bible of
rebaptised if if I was your pastor based
on what you said I would encourage you
to be rebaptised for your own you know
edification in Acts chapter 19 it talks
about some believers that were baptized
by John the Baptist by immersion they
did it the right way but they hadn't
heard about Jesus and they just learned
a lot of new things and they were
rebaptised by Paul and so I think you
should be baptized biblically we have a
lesson we can send you on baptism that
will explain that and it talks about
rebaptised you like a free copy of that
yeah in fact I would like a copy of
everything you're gonna send to the last
like five callers I I also you know am
new new back in the faith and and it's
like wonderful things have been
happening ever sight about six weekends
ago I read from my faith and ever since
then it's really good things happened
and then if something will happen
not so good and medically and physically
it it's been not so good you need some
encouragement guy named Richard Morrow
and he was a sheriff a cop and the car
was on fire
and he came on to the olive tree
ministries - Jan Markell out of
Minnesota and he was telling everybody
the day after it happened she had him
live on the radio and he was telling his
story about how the man was trapped in
the car and how he got out right before
the car was exploding he just said Jesus
I can't get this man out it's up to you
I need you to save him and he said he
reached in through the front door the
fire the entire front of the car was on
fire and the and another guy Eugene came
into the back seat and they and the guy
just literally lifted floated up in the
air turned sideways pulled out and kind
of floated out and he said as soon as he
went back in there after he said that he
said the whole world was kind of sit
still was peaceful as quiet he couldn't
hear the fire he said he just felt a
sense of calmness and he knows it was
Jesus
pulling the man helpful in the man out
and then they stood there and watched
the car burned to the ground and inside
the car
I've heard that Bible a Bible unburned
laying in the burned blackened floor
nothing but the Bible was unburned a
true miracle I believe that's amazing
story that's I know well that's a I'm
thrilled that it gave you that
encouragement Rebecca will be happy to
send you that book on baptism and if you
want to read some of the other books
that we've mentioned you can see them
all and read them for free I think just
about everything we mentioned at the
amazing facts website again just go to
amazing facts dot o-r-g
or amazing facts calm Andy you can go to
our free library and you're welcome to
read all of the resources or call us the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
that is a resource for online and you
can mention specifically the book called
baptism is it
really necessary and we'll be able to
send that to you Rebecca way anybody
wanting to learn more about that subject
our next caller is Raeleen listening
from Virginia we mean welcome to the
program hi thank you I first I want to
thank you for the sincerity of your
program so my question my question comes
in and this is when we're talking about
speaking in tongues I'm very personal
topic for me is can someone the two
people are speaking and speaking of the
gospel and furthering the purposes of
Jesus Christ when they speak to one
another do they hear each other in their
own language the Lord opened that up
here each other in their own you mean if
two people are have got the gift of
tongues like back in the days of the
Apostles and when they're speaking in
tongues would they understand each other
if they both have the gift of tongues is
that what you're asking
correct or even in today's society I had
an experience several years back when I
was flying to another country and spoke
to many people we were all of us on this
very very long trip in the very
Christian centered topic and different
people would come around and we talked
to each other and we were all different
countries and different languages and we
all didn't speak English and I spoke
English I really didn't have that great
as a grab I guess one Spanish were there
people speaking languages that I had no
I have no today I have no clue and we
were understanding one another and to me
it was all in English and I'm wondering
if they heard themselves in their own
language but we were communicating and
very centered on Christ and His purposes
in our interaction with each other
that's a good question you know I I
don't know because it could be a few
different ways but here's what I'll say
when God when when the people in Genesis
11 were disobeying God he confused their
tongues so they couldn't understand each
other in Acts chapter 2 when the
Apostles were praying and sharing and
obeying
God removed the curse of Babylon so they
could understand and when people are on
mission trips and they're doing the work
of God it seems like the Spirit is there
to give understanding and interpretation
and so it's more likely that if it's the
spirit working that people do have a
discernment and understanding but I
can't say as every situation might be a
little different right it was just
amazing to me that was later on after
that experience I thought wait a second
how did we understand one another they
did not speak English
I've heard that several times before you
know you would probably really enjoy the
book that we've been talking about if
you don't read it online you could read
it online right now for free called
understanding tongues and I go through a
personal experience I believe in that
book something that happened to me where
I picked up a Spanish hitchhiker and
well I'll let you read it I won't tell
you anyway just if you'd like a free
copy of that the number to call is 883
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the book called understanding tongue
so I'll be happy to send that to anybody
who calls and asks I next call ease
ghena listening from Rio Linda
California Jeana welcome to the program
[Music]
the area plants no ID but the reason for
my call is about marijuana I'm very
disappointed in the voters of my States
okay Matt and I see so much harm being
done I've seen the environment when the
toxins are poor than our creeks and
rivers the air is not clean oxygen
degrees I see children with asthma
because their folks are smoking pot
around them and I see you know that the
crime involved with it and when people
that don't have money to be buying that
in the first place they you know turn to
other cry
to get money to buy pot so is your
question about is where does the Bible
say something about marijuana or unclean
plants what I've heard before in the
past well when sin entered earth just
like how beautiful roses have thorns now
and in one way they wouldn't have the
thorns to hurt us you know what I mean
with the beautiful road well there's
this harmful ask you and I guess it's a
two-part question because just because
the majority of men say something is OK
or faith a certain way right alone to
follow what God says God's Word and and
so again even though they vote well let
me answer we're gonna run out of time I
want to be able to try and give you some
kind of answer here there obviously
there are different purposes there's a
reason for everything God made I'm of
the opinion that I don't see a lot of
good coming from marijuana and I'm
coming from someone who before I was a
Christian I grew it I smoked it and I
you know I did inhale I know all about
it I have some property in Mendocino
County our families had for 40 years
that just a lot of our neighbors are
growing pot and we've seen what it does
to the environment we've seen the crime
we've had neighbors killed over it and
you know Jesus said you'll know them by
their fruits
I don't see a lot of good fruit coming
from the whole marijuana culture and
industry I would not say that I think
that there are different purposes for
drugs that may be abused
for example people shouldn't smoke
tobacco but if you put tobacco on an ant
bite it actually helps you know what I'm
saying yeah and so there there's
misapplication of some plants God you
know they're marijuana you can make rope
out of it means you know doesn't mean
you got to smoke the Rope so there's a
lot of things that are missile I'd so I
don't want to stop short I want to stop
short before I say that you know some
plants are just all evil there's nothing
good about them yeah I mean not all
plants are good for humans I think
that's just the bottom line this
mushrooms that if you eat you die that's
right and you know there's these reasons
why they poisonous because it protects
the mushroom so just because it's a
plant it doesn't necessarily mean that
it's good for us to eat it or smoke it
or whatever else people do with that
it's it's you know some plants is good
but some plants is he's poisonous not
good I picked up a hitchhiker once that
was he was wearing a white robe and
sandals no no no sandals he was barefoot
and he was part of a Jesus Movement that
they just kind of traveled around
wearing white robes and they said that
and they smoked pot and he asked me if I
had any and I said no I don't smoke he
said well I I said it's not good for you
said oh God made it it's an herb I saw
God doesn't want us to smoke all the
plants that he made but he really
believed it was an herb and he said
we're you know the herb of the field was
made for us and he was making this big
argument but I didn't really buy that I
don't think it's biblical either but hey
we appreciate your question Dina and
hope that helps a little bit yeah there
are some plants that are obviously
unclaimed for food there may be a
purpose form but doesn't mean we're
supposed to eat and smoke I don't think
we're supposed to smoke anything that's
right it's not good for the lungs next
qualities Larry listening in Sacramento
California
hi Larry hi hi we got just about a
minute Larry can we do a quick question
yes let me get some critters from you
about suicide my wife took her life some
years ago and she killed herself in the
house while I was there with a handgun
and I wanted to find out what the Bible
has to say about it let me give you a
little bit quiting background as quickly
as I can
we had been believers before that she
had grown up in a Christian home we she
and I had gone to church after we had
gotten married and she fell away and
became depressed went to alcohol and I
couldn't help her and she ended up
taking her life because of depression so
she was on are you wondering Larry I
don't want to cut you off because it's
such an important question but I don't
want to leave you without an answer are
you wondering does this mean it can a
person who can
suicide can they be saved or yet is
there hope okay that's often the
question about that I think that there
are examples in the Bible of people that
took their lives maybe through great
discouragement Samson actually took his
own life but the last thing that
happened was he was filled with the
spirit and I think Samson will be in the
kingdom most suicides unfortunately are
an example of people who have lost faith
which is typically not a good sign but
you know God knows what's going on in a
person's mind and what stresses are
going through and so we got to be very
careful to know that God loves them more
than we do we'll have to leave that in
his hands until the great resurrection
Thank You Larry for your call all of you
some if we didn't get to your question
tonight we hope you give us another
chance next week and make sure there's a
lot more answers available if you simply
go to the amazing facts website amazing
facts dot o-r-g we'll talk more next
week
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world beyond the Great Wall the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
motion southeast Ohio faith oxygen Tian
Xiang Yan China - the amazing facts
Chinese language website is now one of
our most visited websites we also
translated thousands of pieces of
literature for these nations what
started out as hundreds of followers is
now in the hundreds of thousands the
impact of your funds invested in sharing
the everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come
you know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry god bless you I really
wanted to start a new devotional habit
but life got in the way next thing I
know we're a month into the new year and
I'm like what's the point of starting
then I saw 365 amazing answers to big
Bible questions each day is a single
study so you can start anywhere on any
day and not
they're crisp clear and enlightening get
yours today by calling
[Music]